The Asian grocery store is one of our favorite places.
We just don't get to go a lot because it's so far.
But when we do go,
we stock up.
So we always start in the produce section.
I need to get papayas,
some mushrooms,
and then I browse all the green leafy vegetables.
I decided to get some Guy Lawn today.
I also got some bean sprouts and garlic.
And then Lucky's always in charge of the meat.
He always likes to stock up on some wagyu.
And lucky needed to get this soda
cause it looked really intriguing to him.
We made it over to the ramen section,
and there's two ramens we like to eat,
so we got normal tonkatsu
and then black garlic tonkatsu.
And then I've been seeing these buldak ramens
all over my for you page,
but they didn't have the flavor I wanted,
so I moved on and got some cucumber kimchi
and normal kimchi.
Also stocked up on some frozen udon.
These spicy pork dumplings are so good.
Stocked up on some gyoza
and then some essential sauces that we ran out of.
I was trying to find Boba ice cream
and this viral mango ice cream.
Couldn't find either of those,
so we ended up leaving without it,
which I was sad about.
But this wraps up our trip.